the jogan experience the stuff in the
sea very alien like yeah I agree you
know they they did some study recently
where they showed that jellyfish despite
not having a brain they seemed to be
able to learn now they're go now they're
trying to figure out well how are they
learn it I know how they learn how Vibes
Vibes man they feel The Vibes they feel
The Vibes you have to have a brain to
feel the Vibes if we live in a
vibrational Universe where everything is
frequency it would make sense they The
Vibes they're vibing out down there they
just go with what the flow is they're
very uh they're very jelly likee they
just go with whatever the energy is
doing already that's why it seems like
you guys seems like you came up with
this Theory together and you discussed
this before well I just thought of it
right now and Sarah came on board with
me and I feel like we're on to something
are we not on something no I think we
live in a I think we live in a
vibrational universe and the things
enter our experience based on the things
that we think and the world that we
create and so when you I just think if
the fish are flowing this way the jelly
is going to go this way
too and it seems like they know what
they're doing but they're just kind of
going with whatever is happening around
them some of them are poisonous as [__]
like the box jellyfish which means they
know they need to be poisonous yeah
which means they're aware that there's
danger so they're they sentient in some
way yeah they have no brains but they're
aware I know a lot of people like that
yeah I know a lot of
jellyfish well if especially if you
think about where box jellyfish live
they're Australia right Australia has
great white sharks everywhere Australia
has those little cute um octopi that is
it octopus pie I think it's octopi
octopi that are the little blue ringed
ones that look like you can pick them up
but they'll kill you they're like the
most dangerous World
[__] a James B
movie octopuses the blue ringed octopus
yeah it's like very cute and small and
they have videos of that one that'll
kill you yeah that'll kill you how come
that guy has it on his hand it's like
one of the most de the most deadly
octopus wow
and people pick them up all the time
because they're beautiful I want that in
a jacket and so what what does it have a
stinger like bites I think if I remember
has toxin or some [__] I think it bites
it's nicknamed bro it says blue ringed
octopus nickname bro it only attacks
humans when it feels in danger if you're
trying to corner a blue ring octopus it
might become aggressive in attack so it
has two types of toxins for hunting the
other for self-defense it it a blue ring
octopus ejects tetrodoxin a harmful
toxin that could paralyze and kill a
human adult in mere minutes it's 1,200
times more toxic than cyanide it's crazy
that's wild MH holy [__] there's no
known antidote nope it's the same kind
of toxin that puffer fish have it can
kill 26 full adults with one bite oh my
it's F God it can kill 26 full adults in
one bite yeah
that is so
crazy that is so insane it is insane
right and there's videos of people that
pick it up they go viral because they
don't know better so they're playing
with it in the ocean and it's like oh
God and thank God I mean I think that I
think they've also they had a Netflix
thing about how octopi are like really
smart and they like have the average uh
brain of like a 5-year-old child or
something so maybe some of them are
aware and don't want to kill people when
they get picked up but well they figure
out how to open up mason jars oh yeah
they can they can unlock doors they can
they I think they said that they can
memorize sh they can memorize [__] and
how it works well they F this they had
this tank that was set up next to
another tank so one tank had octopus in
it and the other tank across the room
had fish in it and fish started missing
and so they set up a camera and they
found out what was going on was the
octopus was climbing out of his tank
walking across the floor climbing up
into the other tank jacking a fish
eating it and then going back into his
tank the comedian in me imagine it
jacking off a fish and then eating it
but for some reason for some reason when
I was imagining it the octopus was
wearing sunglasses in the whole
story The Pink Panther songs
like I mean how insane is that that the
thing figured out that it could get out
and walk in a place where it can't
breathe well they can fit through
anything that their eyes can fit fit
through that's crazy no matter how big
they are I think also don't quote me on
that but how would it how would it know
that it could get out and climb I mean
what Joe you want to hear the answer
vies it just knows it just knows the
same way the same way the the everyone
knows everything Vibes Vibes you felt it
out one day you were like this feels
right intuition how two humans the first
two humans know to have sex they were
just like this feels like we should do
that right well but it was way before
humans right how did how did the first
living organism that was multicellular
figure out how to mate a little a little
an innate thing a little horny cell
right little horny cell so what is this
octopus doing oh big octopus versus
small holes they keep they keep giv this
is a pornnhub this is a PornHub
category watching I'm sorry guys is
there a little pent up energy in this
room what's happening big octopus small
hole is disgusting so that little hole
in the plexiglass it's going to go
through that little hole oh yeah and it
could definitely fit cuz his eyeballs
are like a fist I think it actually
might it did four other ones before I
got to this video I think this is that
might stuck yeah I think it backs off it
realizes it's stuck this is a [__]
alien I'm sorry they are aliens how is
that not an alien they really are aliens
they're just aliens that live under the
ocean yeah and do you know that the the
myth of the Kraken Kraken was an
enormous octopus that would take out
ships no yeah it was always like one of
those anent myths of a a Sea Beast they
have paintings with like the octopus
tentacles touching the ships and stuff
one day oh [__] one day they found uh
tentacle imprints the imprints of the
suction cups that were massive that
would have indicated like an enormous
octopus oh yeah they were definitely
taking down shits so they think it was
real yeah they think at one point in
time there really were massive octopus
smart enough to do what that a fossil
the fossilized version of the Kraken so
they found these fossils of the the
suction cups on the bottom of the ocean
floor and they were like
what